>>> THIS MORNING TWO CONNECTICUT
POLICE OFFICERS ARE DEAD AND A
THIRD IS SERIOUSLY WOUNDED AFTER
BEING SHOT RESPONDING TO A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALL.
POLICE ARE SAYING THE 911 CALL
WAS A PLOY TO LURE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO THE SCENE.
THE POLICE CHIEF HONORED THE
FALLEN OFFICERS DURING A
CONFERENCE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> OUR MEN AND WOMEN OF THE
BRISTOL POLICE DEPARTMENT ARE
PRIVILEGED AND HONORED TO SERVE
ON THE FRONT LINES PROTECTING
AND SERVING THE COMMUNITY OF
P
BRISTOL.
THAT'S WHAT THESE HEROES DID
LAST NIGHT.
>> ALEXANDRIA FIELDS JOINS ME
NOW.
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING?
>> Reporter: IT APPEARS THE
OFFICERS WERE LED DIRECTLY INTO
AN AMBUSH STARTING WITH A 911
CALLED REPORTING A DOMESTIC
INCIDENT BETWEEN SIBLINGS.
IT APPEARS WHEN THEY ARRIVED
THEY WERE CONFRONTED OUTSIDE BY
A SUSPECT.
A NEIGHBOR DESCRIBES HEARING A
HAIL OF BULLETS THAT FOLLOWED.
>> IT WAS LIKE A BURST OF TEN OR
SO GUN SHOTS AND THEN THERE WAS
ANOTHER BURST.
AND MY HUSBAND RAN DOWNSTAIRS
AND LOOKED OUT THE WINDOW AND
WENT OFF AGAIN.
THE SIRENS WERE CRAZY.
IT WAS JUST LIKE A WAR ZONE.
>> Reporter: SERGEANT DUST TIN
DEMONTY, OFFICER ALEC HEMZI BOTH
KILLED.
A THIRD OFFICER WAS SHOT AND
INJURED.
THE SUSPECT SHOT AND KILLED, HIS
BROTHER SHOT AND INJURED.
POLICE ARE CALLING THIS A
COMPLEX AND ONGOING
INVESTIGATION.
>> IN THE CLIP WE PLAYED YOU
COULD TELL THE CHIEF WAS
EMOTIONAL, VISIBLY SO.
WE UNDERSTOOD THE OFFICERS WERE
WELL RESPECTED AND REVERED IN
THE COMMUNITY.
HOW IS THAT COMMUNITY IN
BRISTOL, CONNECTICUT RESPONDING?
>> Reporter: THEY'RE REELING
FROM THE LOSS OF OFFICERS LOST
IN THE LINE OF DUTY AND
STRUGGLING TO COMPREHEND WHETHER
THE OFFICERS WERE PART OF A
CALCULATED SHOOTING.
ALL OF THIS WEIGHING ON THE
HEARTS AND MINDS OF THOSE WHO
LOVED THESE TWO YOUNG MEN.
WE KNOW SERGEANT DEMONTY, IS
SURVIVED BY A WIFE AND TWO
CHILDREN A THIRD CHILD ON THE
WAY.
BOTH BEING CALLED BRAVE AND
EXCEPTIONAL OFFICERS.
>> A THIRD CHILD ON THE WAY,
WHAT A DEVASTATING STORY.